j'ouvre notre second débat vous le savez
on le choisit le plus souvent possible
volontairement décalé de l'actualité du
jour et il est consacré ce soir à la
stratégie du rassemblement national la
diabolisation débutée il y a une dizaine
d'années commence à porter ses fruits
d'hypothèse de voir le parti d'extrême
droite arriver un jour au pouvoir n'est
plus aussi improbable est-ce possible
des 2027 avant d'en débattre gros plan
sur ces députés le pénis qui ont joué
pendant toute la séquence retraite tout
ce bras de fer la carte du calme et de
la sobriété Adrien pain
vous êtes in
existe vous une opposition en carton qui
a chaque moment de faiblesse du
gouvernement venait à son soutien ils
sont passés presque inaperçus lors de
l'examen de la réforme des retraites sur
20000 amendements les députés du RN n'en
ont déposé que 200 ils ont pris la
parole qu'à deux rares occasions une
attitude aux antipodes de celle des
insoumis au palais Bourbons se
comportait comme un parti responsable
capable d'incarner l'alternance à
Emmanuel Macron cette stratégie réussie
au groupe RN qui compte bien continuer
sur cette ligne pour les textes à venir
c'est la stratégie qui a décidé Marine
Le Pen et le groupe en juin on c'est
d'ailleurs la stratégie qu'on avait même
avant par exemple dans les conseils
régionaux dans les conseils
départemental dans les conseils
départementaux pardon donc c'est pas
nouveau en fait ça a été toujours
l'attitude du marinisme après il faut
faire attention le fait d'être calme de
ne pas mettre de bordel à l'Assemblée ou
de respecter les institutions
ça n'empêche pas d'avoir une opposition
très dure sur le fond et sur le fond je
pense qu'on est extrêmement dur avec la
majorité nous sommes même
idéologiquement les plus opposés à ce
qu'ils font
cette discrétion semble payante si l'on
en croit de récents sondage selon une
enquête délab publiée début avril Marine
Le Pen remporterait même la
présidentielle si elle avait lieu
aujourd'hui avec les candidats de 2022
Marine Le Pen est avec Fabien Roussel la
seule personnalité qui apparaît
renforcée dans la séquence que nous
venons de vivre il y a toujours un côté
repoussoir auprès de quelques catégories
de population les retraités des
professions intellectuels les cas de
supérieures mais la le FN le
jean-marieme le fnrn diabolisé celui qui
ne séduisait que des catégories très
spécifiques des jeunes des ouvriers des
personnes non diplômées ce Jean-Marie
cela semble avoir vécu pour poursuivre
sa normalisation le RN mise sur la
formation de ces militants c'est le
cheval de bataille de Jordan Bardella le
président du parti a lancé fin mars une
école pour ses futurs cadres
de servir et je vous présente tout de
suite mes invités dans ce second débat
freak Pothier bonsoir bienvenue vous
êtes expert associés à la Fondation Jean
Jaurès et codirector de l'Observatoire
des radicalités politiques Marie mollet
bonsoir bienvenue vous êtes journaliste
au service politique de RTL et
spécialiste du rassemblement national
Hugo palette et sociologue doit être bah
voilà ça s'appelle une entrée théâtrale
bienvenue bonsoir à vous heureux de vous
accueillir vous êtes maître de
conférence à l'Université de Lille et
auteur de ce livre la nouvelle
internationale fasciste qui est publié
aux éditions textuelles et Guillaume
d'arrêt évidemment à mes côtés ce qui
est bien sympathique Frédéric potier ce
plan de sobriété c'est le terme qui
était employé
par le député RN à l'Assemblée voulu par
Marine Le Pen est-ce qu'il est en train
de porter ses fruits point de se briété
pendant la première année la devise
lature et puis notamment pendant le
toute la séquence retraite oui elle est
évident je pense qu'il a porté ses
fruits on voit que l'image du
rassemblement national a évolué on voit
que la dédiabolisation
a été presque achevée le rassemblement
national est considéré comme un parti
comme les autres avec des porte-pables
des porte-paroles plutôt crédible on
vient d'avoir un à l'écran donc oui
cette stratégie elle est plutôt payante
pour l'instant Marie mollet est-ce que
cette stratégie je parle là de la
réforme des retraites de cette séquence
spécifique donc quasi silence ou en tout
cas sobriété en contraste avec avec la
Nupe et LFI est-ce que elle a été
facilement acceptée par par tout
l'encadrement du rassemblement national
ou est-ce que c'est vraiment la
stratégie de Marine Le Pen il a dû un
peu l'imposer non alors c'est déjà enfin
cette stratégie elle porte ses fruits
donc elle crée le consensus ce qui est
amusant c'est que au départ avant le
début de cette séquence des retraites le
RN était conscient que ça pouvait être
un moment un peu compliqué
paradoxalement parce que le RN marche
sur une ligne de crête c'est-à-dire que
à la fois il doit donner des gages à son
socle populaire à son socle traditionnel
c'est-à-dire donner des gages sur le
volet social donc en s'opposant à la
réforme mais d'un autre côté le but
c'est d'aller à la conquête d'autres
électorat et en l'espèce é de droite
donc effectivement avec
exactement et donc ne pas lui faire peur
et c'est précisément ce qui explique en
fait ces stratégie de la discrétion du
silence je ne sais pas mais en tout cas
de cette discrétion pour et bien tenir
ce chemin de crête garder son socle et
aller à la conquête d'un autre socle
parce qu'effectivement la retraite à 60
ans ça parle pas forcément aux électeurs
et l'air historiques exactement et c'est
aussi la raison pour laquelle elle a
évolué sur sur ce point elle est passée
à 62 ans et puis effectivement tout la
question le rapport à la rue également
qu'elle a qu'elle a elle a essayé
justement de manorer alors elle est pas
la bienvenue dans la rue donc ça réglait
la question c'est de dire chacun peut
aller dans la rue s'il le souhaite je
n'irai pas mais les Français qui veulent
le faire peuvent le faire sans
difficulté alors il y a les chiffres il
faut rappeler plus de 41% des suffrages
exprimés au second tour de la
présidentielle ça représente 13 millions
288 686 personnes qui ont voté Marine Le
Pen 88 députés aujourd'hui c'est le
groupe le plus fort de son histoire à
l'Assemblée est-ce que vous diriez que
l'habitude il y a une sorte d'habitude
de voter RN qui s'encre dans une partie
du corps électoral
oui alors effectivement en plus c'est un
contraste assez en contraste avec ce qui
se jouait dans les années 90 ou c'est un
électorat plutôt volatile enfin qui
pouvait être volatils dans les années
2010 qui se s'affirme c'est
effectivement un vote qui se répète
d'une élection d'une élection à une
autre donc ça c'est effectivement la
grande réussite de Marine Le Pen de
cette ancrée donc notamment dans
certains dans certaines franges des
classes populaires certains territoire
plutôt les petites villes plutôt les
zones rurales ou semi rurales donc là
effectivement il y a quelque chose qui a
changé effectivement qui est
l'expression d'une d'une normalisation
dans le paysage politique mais
normalisation qui n'est pas simplement
le produit de leur stratégie ou d'une
bonne habilité etc bon ils peuvent être
relativement habiles plus ou moins selon
les différents papas mais qui est lié à
l'évolution du champ politique français
qui a progressivement intégré le RN
comme potentiellement une alternance
normale là où dans la dernière période
c'est le Front républicain c'est presque
en quelque sorte reconstituer mais
contre la France insoumise alors
justement je voudrais en faire un petit
est-ce que vous vous parlez encore envie
d'extrême droite alors moi je parle
encore d'un parti d'extrême droite mais
il y a un débat il y a un débat y
compris à la Fondation Jean Jaurès
d'ailleurs entre ceux qui considèrent
que c'est devenu un parti de droite
radical comme on envoie d'autres aux
États-Unis en Italie moi je conseille
qu'il y a quand même un vieux fonds
d'extrême droite on voit sur les
positions liées à l'immigration aux
étrangers mais le fait que le débat soit
ouvert montre bien que le parti a évolué
et que le champ politique a évolué Hugo
pas l'étage justement derrière la façade
est-ce qu'il y a toujours un fond
idéologique d'extrême droite vous suffit
de regarder les 22 premières mesures les
22 mesures de Marine Le Pen les trois
premières c'est des mêmes que celle du
Front national de toujours c'est le tour
de premièrement de l'immigration et donc
autour notamment de la ce qu'ils
appellent maintenant la priorité
nationale mais ce qu'ils ont longtemps
appelé la préférence nationale ensuite
l'islam avec la fermeture de nombreux
lieux de culte et et l'insécurité donc
il y a ce point là sur le fond
idéologique je ne crois pas qu'ils aient
fondamentalement changé d'ailleurs en
réalité la plupart des cadres sont des
cadres qui ont été formés par les vieux
cadres du Front national Marine Le Pen
en premier lieu entrée au FN 86 elle a
dû avaler toutes les couleurs
antisémites prononcées par son père sans
jamais sans jamais élever la voix à
l'époque où il y a lieu par exemple et
par ailleurs les alliés de Marine Le Pen
autre plan international il y a pas
photo c'est c'est des leaders d'extrême
droite d'ailleurs elle s'était elle
s'était félicité de l'arrivée au pouvoir
de bolsonaro elle s'était félicité Larry
au pouvoir de Trump son allié en Europe
c'est Orban qui mène une politique à la
fois
ultra-nationaliste et réactionnaire sur
le plan des droits des minorités
notamment des femmes et des GBT mais par
ailleurs des politiques très violemment
néolibérales donc on voit un peu quand
même malgré tout quel est le type de
projet politique qui est celui de du
rassemblement national aujourd'hui à la
fois d'extrême droite et en grande
partie néolibérale par exemple sur le
plan international c'est d'ailleurs
intéressant de noter qu'il y a une
interview qui nous a un peu échappé en
France la semaine dernière de Jordan
Bardella je crois qui a été donné en
Italie dans lequel il prend ses
distances avec Georgia mélony en disant
en gros notre proximité c'est pas
Georges jameloni c'est Matteo Salvini
donc ça replace bien idéologiquement
Marine Le Pen et le rassemblement
national
dans la lignée de Salvini et pas dans la
lignée de mélonie qui se veut plus
respectable au niveau international
est-ce que c'est un débat dans vos
rédactions respectives de l'utiliser le
terme extrême droite quand on parle du
rassemblement national je reste avec
vous Guillaume et je vous poserai la
question j'ai pas été moi pour l'instant
j'ai jamais été confronté dans un sujet
ou dans un direct ou dans une analyse à
se débat là donc pour l'instant je peux
pas dire que c'est un débat d'accord
marine ce débat c'est le journaliste
rubrick car en charge qui le tranche
donc en l'occurrence à RTL moi et
j'utilise j'utilise le terme extrême
droite pour les raisons qui viennent
d'être évoquées c'est à dire que le
substrat idéologique reste le même
c'est-à-dire l'abrogation du droit du
sol la suppression de la me la
préférence nationale et tout ça ça
rattache Marine Le Pen a la famille de
l'extrême droite même si effectivement
elle a mis en sourdine ce sujet là
pendant la présidentielle oui alors ce
qui était étonnant enfin hypothier c'est
que alors là c'est peut-être la séquence
qui veut ça mais elle a pratiquement
plus besoin de parler d'immigration
c'est comme si c'était quoi intégré dans
l'esprit des citoyens des électeurs
français que bah elle était en le matin
je mets des guillemets sur sur ces
thématiques là oui c'est tout à fait
frappant on a l'impression qu'il y a un
socle électoral un socle politique qui
fait que elle pourrait spontanément
capitaliser sur la sécurité et
l'immigration et c'est très frappant de
voir le rassemblement national
aujourd'hui investir des sujets comme
ceux de la bataille culturelle avec ses
attaques contre le wokisme il y a eu un
colloque c'est ça qui a été organisé des
positions et des rapports qui sont faits
par exemple sur la question des zones à
faible affaiblission donc la question
écologique la question des cons
l'intelligence artificielle
oui alors il y a un effet de rente ils
ont une rente idéologique et politique
sur les questions enfin sur les non pas
les thématiques de l'immigration sur la
xénophobie sur le fait de contester le
droit du sol contester les droits pour
les minorités pour des gens qui
travaillent parfois ici depuis 10 ans 20
ans d'avoir les mêmes droits etc la
préférence nationale donc ils ont une
rente et par ailleurs le fait d'aller de
faire des incursions sur d'autres sujets
c'est pas nouveau ça fait 30 ans c'était
le projet Bruno Maigret dans les années
90 il y avait déjà dans dans la revue du
Front national national Hebdo et ils
avaient fait des Colocs à l'époque sur
l'écologie c'est pas du tout nouveau
même le social ils l'ont investi à ce
moment-là parce que précisément le Parti
communiste est graissait dans la
population notamment la pollution
ouvrière ils se sont dit il y a un
terrain pour nous donc c'est on a
parfois pu dire que Marine c'est du
maigritisme sans maigrir mais du point
de vue de la stratégie bien sûr c'est ça
c'est sur les fondamentaux tout en
allant faire des incursions pour draguer
d'autres pendre l'électorat alors dans
cette stratégie de normalisation il y a
aussi l'accès Marie-Mai la dépose de
responsabilité à l'Assemblée nationale
deux vices présidents sur 6 4
secrétaires sur 12 comment est-ce qu'on
porte dans ce on peut prendre l'exemple
de Sébastien Chenu qui est peut-être le
plus médiatiquement visible de
des lieutenants de Marine Le Pen à
l'Assemblée comment il se comporte comme
vice-président il se comporte j'allais
dire normalement c'est tout l'objectif
mais pour eux c'est une image qui est un
cadeau formidable c'est quel cadeau pour
marquer cet institut cette
institutionnalisation un président de
séance au perchoir entrant en train de
dire un peu de calme chers collègues
c'était précisément le but effectivement
de cette normalisation et en ce sens la
majorité a fait un cadeau rassemblement
national puisque vous le savez ce sont
les députés qui votent pour que des
groupes puissent avoir Davis président
et la majorité a décidé bien de donner
des postes au rassemblement national
contre la vie de la nups donc
effectivement c'est un cadeau qui a été
fait au rassemblement alors Sébastien
Chenu on va justement l'entendre
réaction sur la stratégie pendant ces
débats sur la réforme des retraites on
écoute le vice-président de l'Assemblée
également député du Nord
je pense que il y a d'un côté des gens
irresponsables de l'autre côté des gens
qui ont peur de ne pas avoir la majorité
bon ben écoutez nous on est là pour être
sérieux nous on a déposé des amendes de
fonds pas des amendements pour mobiliser
du temps pour discuter réellement de la
pénibilité de l'âge du départ en
retraite c'est ce qui intéresse les
Français alors on reviendra sur les gens
irresponsables évidemment ici le la nu-p
et la France insoumise mais je voudrais
petit revenir sur peut-être les
résultats voir si ça marche cette
stratégie auprès de l'électorat il y a
eu deux élections partielles une en
Ariège et une dans la Marne si je ne me
trompe alors ce sont des partiels il y a
peu de participation on va pas
extrapoler mais quand même ils ont pas
été bons alors dans la Marne la sortante
à son émotionnelle a été battue par une
candidate de la majorité présidentielle
et en Ariège le rassemblement national
n'était pas au second tour alors qu'il
l'était en 2022 après il faut prendre
avec beaucoup de recul ces élections
partielles parce que il y a peu de
mobilisation l'électorat RN se
mobilisent peu lors des partiels c'est
un électorat plutôt populaire donc il
faut pas en tirer de grandes le mais
c'est quand même intéressant c'est quand
même des signaux qu'il faut qu'il faut
intégrer qu'il faut appréhender
c'est-à-dire que c'est quand même un
parti Mary mollet qui a critiqué le
système pendant pendant des années voir
des décennies et qui est maintenant
essaie de se montrer le plus sobre
possible dans le système il y a sans
doute un une contradiction pour une
partie de l'électorat le pénis alors en
tout cas c'est effectivement tout le
paradoxe et se couler dans les
institutions mais il faut quand même
garder un avantage concurrentiel donc ça
va être effectivement la difficulté mais
je suis assez d'accord c'est quand même
un signal qu'il faut pas négliger dans
tout le récit qui est fait en ce moment
de de la marche la marche vers le
pouvoir cette élection législative
partielle c'était une configuration qui
était différente mais c'est un signal
qui est pas totalement neutre
effectivement on voit que la marche ne
sera pas forcément un tapis rouge
évidemment quand Sébastien Chenu cible
des gens irresponsables ils parlent de
la de la nuque ou de la nupesse est-ce
que vous diriez quand même que par le
choix c'est la stratégie de Jean-Luc
Mélenchon là de tout conflictualiser
est-ce que
ça facilite pas aussi la normalisation
du rassemblement national en effet
miroir on est en plein conflit social de
très grandes ampleur très grande
intensité c'est assez logique que la
gauche et sa composante peut-être la
plus à gauche soit dans ce registre là
de confrontation sociale les stratégie
elle a précédé la réforme des retraites
quand même oui bien sûr mais bon disons
que moi je suis en tout cas assez
sceptique sur le fait qu'il y aurait un
espèce de raz-de-marée pour Marine Le
Pen elle est dans son rôle si vous
voulez qu'on lui a donné et qu'elle a
acquis parce qu'elle était là au second
tour donc elle est premier reposante le
pouvoir est fragilisé par le mouvement
social c'est assez normal que un peu
mécaniquement dans les sondages elle
progresse à ce stade là ça dit pas grand
chose de ça dit pas grand chose de la
suite d'autant plus qu'en réalité je
crois que les médias ont peu insister
sur le fait que pour moi cette séquence
a aussi révélé les faiblesses ou les
incapacités de du RN alors ils se font
tout petits mais on voit en fait en
réalité une faiblesse du côté de l'ordre
ils ont peu de cadres à notamment à
l'Assemblée en réalité pour intervenir
pour proposer des amendements etc ils
ont une très faible influence dans la
société ils ont pas l'influence que peut
avoir la Nupe dans le mouvement social
par exemple ils ont pas de capacité à
mobiliser dans la rue etc si quand même
pour une force politique depuis 19e
siècle et quelque chose d'important donc
et par ailleurs sur le plan
programmatique c'est pas très cohérent
elle fait croire qu'elle est encore pour
l'arrêter à 60 ans pour une partie de
son électorat mais en réalité on voit
bien que c'est pas seulement que c'est
passé à 62 ans pour certains dans son
projet ça passerait à 67 ans donc en
fait il y a une retraite modulable selon
l'entrée dans la vie active entre 60 et
67 ans d'une certaine on en parle très
peu on se félicite beaucoup de disons la
stratégie mais d'une certaine manière on
va beaucoup dans le sens du RN ça ça
stratégie discursive c'est de dire nous
avons une sorte de voie royale jusqu'à
2027 si on passe le temps à son temps à
dire que c'est génial ils sont ce sont
des très grands stratèges ça marche à
fond etc c'est vrai que on leur on leur
favorise le terrain alors ça pose
évidemment Guillaume la stratégie la
question de la stratégie des autres
forces politiques et notamment de
l'exécutif le gouvernement qui semble
moins offensifs à l'égard du
rassemblement national ces derniers mois
Emmanuel Macron le premier parce que
c'est vrai qu'il y a un vrai changement
de cap par rapport au premier mandat où
on accuse même le chef de l'État en
quelque sorte de cette choisie sa
première opposante puisqu'elle avait
théorisé vous savez cette opposition
disait-il entre nationalisme finalement
et européen qu'il défendaient en
première ligne notamment lors des
précédentes élections européennes on
voit qu'aujourd'hui il tape d'abord sur
la nuque et en particulier les filles
évidemment parce qu'il veut essayer de
continuer à fracturer la gauche parce
que aux yeux d'électorat de droite ça
lui permet aussi d'apparaître comme le
garant des institutions et de l'ordre la
majorité plus largement tape moins sur
les RN aussi parce que les
parlementaires de renaissance notamment
vous explique bien que il leur semble
plus lisse qu'ils ont moins de prises
dans le débat public ce qui est une
évidence quand on le constate et puis je
vais peut-être apparaître un peu cynique
mais certains députés de la majorité le
disent clairement en off comme on dit
dans une assemblée nationale où la Major
n'a qu'une majorité relative c'est
peut-être pas inutile de temps en temps
même s'il y a évidemment aucun accord
formel d'avoir une partie de ces députés
RN qui votent certains textes alors
est-ce que cette relative clémence
inquiète ou interroge dans la majorité
oui ça interroge d'ailleurs en premier
lieu la première ministre Elisabeth
borne qui en privé salaire tant quelque
sorte du rôle qui est d'après l'essai
par les républicains et une partie de la
gauche à Marine Le Pen elle estime que
finalement ces deux forces lui laissent
je cite le monopole de la responsabilité
et elle s'en alerte particulièrement ça
alerte aussi toute une partie de l'aile
gauche du gouvernement particulier des
ministres comme par exemple Clément
Beaune qui expliquait d'ailleurs dans la
presse il y a quelques jours
publiquement je cite il ne faut pas
perdre notre boussole c'est la menace de
l'extrême droite et plus franchement il
y en a un qui me disaient c'est pas
parce que les députés RN sont sympas et
nous serrent la main à la buvette qu'il
faut oublier qu'elles sont leurs
conviction et leur programme et Emmanuel
Macron alors Emmanuel Macron quand vous
parlez avec ses proches il vous explique
il a une hantise en quelque sorte c'est
d'être le chef de l'État qui
accueillerait Marine Le Pen sur le
perron de l'Elysée en 2027 pour la
passation de pouvoir et que donc il fera
absolument tout pour éviter cela y
compris voilà absolument comme Obama
avec Trump et qu'il fera tout pour
éviter ça et que donc il soutiendra
quelque soit le candidat de son camp
même s'il y a comme toujours parfois des
inimitives personnelles que ce soit par
exemple avec Bruno Le Maire ou avec
Edouard Philippe donc le chef de l'État
dans les prochains jours et c'est ce
qu'on voit dans son interview parisien
hier a décidé aussi de reprendre ce
combat contre le rassemblement national
alors ça passera pas du tout par une
rediabolisation en quelque sorte ce
qu'il considère comme un outil et une
arme politique c'est ce qu'il revendique
finalement comme un discours de vérité
je reprends la citation d'ailleurs de
ces propos dans Le Parisien hier je le
cite Marine Le Pen arrivera si on ne
sait pas répondre au défi du pays et si
on installe une habitude du mensonge ou
du déni du réel c'est ce que des chefs
de l'État pour avoir plus de clarté ça
veut dire qu'il veut parler de tout je
le cite sans tabou à commencer par
l'immigration mais ça veut dire là que
ces opposants vont considérer au
contraire qu'il favorise le
rassemblement c'est passionnant ce que
vous dites parce que là on a une
citation qui qui a été publiée ce matin
mais si on remonte quelques années en
arrière écoutez une intervention du chef
de l'État le soir de sa première
victoire à la présidentielle on est le 7
mai 2017 voilà ce que nous dit le tout
nouveau président Macron je veux enfin
avoir un mot pour ceux qui ont voté
aujourd'hui pour Madame Le Pen
ne les sifflez pas
ils ont exprimé ils ont exprimé
aujourd'hui une colère
un désarroi
parfois des convictions
je les respecte
mais je ferai tout durant les 5 années
qui viennent pour qu'il n'ait plus
aucune raison de voter pour les extrêmes
fabrique potier a-t-il vraiment tout
fait pour empêcher ça ou est-ce que au
contraire on revient à ce que nous
décrivait Guillaume d'arrêt tout à
l'heure finalement c'était un peu la
l'opposante idéale quoi dans une
perspective de ce contour pour Emmanuel
Macron je crois qu'il y a quand même un
risque de piège assez gros quand même
parce que allez vouloir
chercher le rassemblement national sur
la sécurité l'immigration notamment au
Parlement je crois pas que les
parlementaires du assommant national
leur front ce cadeau de voter les textes
gouvernementaux trouveront toujours que
ça va pas assez loin que c'est pas assez
dur et moi ma crainte ma crainte on peut
faire une partie des textes même si
votre une partie déteste alors ils le
feront avec courtoisie et
beaucoup de délicatesse puisque c'est
désormais le style qui est qui est
choisi mais j'ai bien peur qu'à trop
vouloir aller sur le terrain là le
gouvernement se prive ce qui était au
départ l'ADN du macronisme c'est-à-dire
le même temps le centre gauche le centre
droit là on a quand même l'impression
d'avoir quelque chose qui dérive quand
même très doucement et de manière
structurelle et sans limite vers la
droite Hugo palette assez est-ce que
c'est pour vous une erreur
au-delà de la stratégie une erreur de ne
pas de ne pas s'attaquer au contenu du
programme de regarder vraiment ce que
vous décriviez tout à l'heure quel est
le programme du rassemblement national
quel programme en matière de retraite
pourquoi pourquoi ça n'a pas été fait
selon vous par le gouvernement par
l'exécutif pendant ce débat sur les
retraites
est-ce que c'est simplement parce qu'il
donnait pas prise en étant les plus
discrets possible ou est-ce que c'est il
y avait une part de volonté parce que je
pense qu'une partie déjà du programme
actuel du RN étant continuité avec ce
que propose Emmanuel Macron enfin sur
les impôts par exemple de production
qu'il faudrait baisser sur le même y
compris sur le projet de réforme des
retraites l'opposition frontale c'est de
porter par la nuque sur la retraite à 60
ans etc bon mais pour revenir sur le
sujet il y a cette vieille citation de
Jean-Marie Le Pen qui est à la fin les
gens préfèrent l'original à la copie
donc effectivement c'est une stratégie
perdante ça fait 40 ans que ça stratégie
mise en oeuvre enfin peut-être 30 ans
depuis notamment Jacques Chirac c'est à
cette occasion là d'ailleurs quand il
avait tenu des discours anti-migré sur
le bruit et l'odeur que Jean-Marie Le
Pen avait dit je me félicite des propos
de Monsieur Chirac et en gros à la fin
les gens votent pour nous et c'est vrai
c'est ça qui va se passer mais c'est
vrai que c'est la tentation de tous les
gouvernements depuis 30 ans quand ils
sont en ils ont quand ils ont un
problème de consentement c'est à leur
politique de privatisation ou de ou sur
les retraites par exemple c'est d'aller
sur le terrain de la xénophobie
d'aller sur le terrain y compris de
l'autoritarisme et en fait ça
crédibilise à chaque fois l'extrême
droite et à terme enfin c'est ce qu'on a
vu depuis bon il y avait eu l'exemple
aussi de valse en 2016 et de Hollande
sur la déchéance de nationalité qui
était une mesure uniquement proposée par
l'extrême droite auparavant donc tout ça
ça a eu des effets ça a crédibilisé
banalisé le Front national depuis 30 ans
donc là la vérité des prix c'est ça
Marie mollet est-ce qu'il y a eu
effectivement un débat au sein de au
sein de la majorité pour s'attaquer un
peu plus au rassemblement national
notamment sur le sur les retraites
pointées d'éventuelles contradictions
dans le programme de Marine Le Pen sur
les retraites en fait je pense que la
question des contredours ça va être la
grande question comment revitaliser
comment rénover les contre discours et
en fait cette question elle est pas
tranchée y compris dans la majorité
parce que il y a deux stratégies
effectivement c'est soit de dire bon
maintenant on raffermit le Front
républicain on rappelle qu'elle est
d'extrême droite autant de fois qu'il
sera nécessaire ou alors est-ce qu'on se
dit cet argumentaire est effectivement
complètement éculé voire insultant pour
la Torah de Marine Le Pen et donc il est
contre-productif donc voilà
effectivement la grande question c'est
de dire est-ce que on rentre
sérieusement dans le programme c'est
aussi une question qui se pose à gauche
il y a un député EPS qui me disait mais
la vérité c'est qu'on connaît pas bien
le programme de Marine Le Pen on l'a pas
bien analysé mais est-ce que c'est à ce
moment-là pas prendre le risque de la
rendre sérieux en prenant son programme
au sérieux et participer à sa
normalisation pour aller dans votre sens
il y a par exemple des députés de l'aile
droite de la majorité un Guillaume
casbariant par exemple qui dit maman
donné il va falloir qu'on soit très
offensif sur l'immigration pour
siphonner l'extrême droite un peu comme
l'ont fait les Danois c'est-à-dire
récupérer un programme
extrêmement agressif et brutal sur
l'immigration pour et bien faire baisser
l'extrême droite effectivement l'extrême
droite a baissé la gauche vous répond
dans cette même majorité ou en tout cas
dans l'algorge de la majorité on va pas
devenir d'extrême droite pour battre
l'extrême droite on va pas s'en sortir
donc en fait ça pose des questions qui
sont absolument fondamentales qui ne
sont pas tranchées et on verra bien
d'ailleurs à ce propos il y a un du côté
du groupe Renaissance il y a une cellule
anti Front national en irrasement
National qui va être activé à la rentrée
parlementaire la gauche va lancer une
convention reconquérir les classes
populaires avec un tour de France dans
les terrains dans les territoires RN
plus une commission d'enquête citoyenne
pour essayer de comprendre comment et
pourquoi et quand la gauche a perdu son
électorat populaire donc on est dans une
phase un peu d'exploration parce qu'en
réalité la gauche et la majorité n'ont
pas eu à se poser avec tant d'acuité la
question de l'arrivée au pouvoir de
Marine Le Pen alors on va vous dire
Emmanuel Macron on sort du premier
second tour de son élection en 2017
c'est que c'est aussi un constat d'échec
puisque 5 ans plus tard certes il est
réélu président de la République mais
Marine Le Pen est à 41% des suffrages au
second tour de l'élection présidentielle
après pour aller dans votre sens je
pense qu'il faut effectivement modérer
les discours qui annoncent déjà Marine
Le Pen à l'Elysée en 2027 parce que même
dans les sondages aujourd'hui veulent
pas les sondages et même dans l'équation
politique c'est-à-dire ce qu'a fait sa
force c'est qu'elle a tout le temps été
dans une position finalement d'opposante
aux candidats jugé favoris ou au
président sortant quel sera son attitude
dans une position peut-être de favorite
à la prochaine élection présidentielle
elle est quand même loin d'être pour
l'instant embarqué sur le début de la
rue du Faubourg saint-honorine pour
l'instant elle joue le miroir le négatif
d'Emmanuel Macron elle a encore fait ce
weekend en allant sur une fois à
Beaucroissant en Isère ou effectivement
elle a eu les images qu'elle était allé
chercher de le de ferveur des fusions
etc mais ce ne sera pas Emmanuel Macron
face à elle donc cette stratégie elle
marche à court terme mais il se sera
quelqu'un d'autre donc il va falloir
qu'elle trouve une autre stratégie
là-dessus une Marine Le Pen favorite ça
change effectivement je le dis pas que
c'est ce qui va se passer mais ça change
forcément la stratégie de tous les
autres oui parce que on ne sort de
l'ambiguïté qu'à son détriment ça c'est
une citation très célèbre et c'est vrai
que en étant favori et non pas outsider
elle va devoir présenter un programme on
va l'attendre au tournant on va attendre
des réponses sur un certain nombre de
points sur lesquels a pas forcément
l'habitude de parler je pense au
logement je pense à l'inflation et c'est
là où et bien il y aura effectivement la
vérité des prix sur la prochaine
campagne et quatre ans c'est quand même
très très long donc là aussi il faut
avoir beaucoup de recul sur ce qui va
venir et on est évidemment ultra
prudents et on tire pas des plans sur la
comète mais pour non rappelez-vous elle
disait que elle ne serait probablement
pas candidate à la prochaine élection
présidentielle ça a duré quoi 6 mois
c'est ça juste après
mais donc pour arriver dans une
éventuelle je mets évidemment tous les
guillemets et la prudence la position de
favorite bah il y a évidemment d'autres
échéances électorales d'ici là il
faudrait bien une figurer on va
justement en parler tout de suite avec
alexandre Poussin parce que la première
des échéances c'est le mois de septembre
rebonsoir Alexandre bonsoir et ce sont
les élections sénatoriales évidemment
effectivement Thomas le 24 septembre
prochain la moitié du Sénat est
renouvelable cela fait quand même 172
sièges de sénateurs qui sont remises en
jeu on le rappelle actuellement le
rassemblement national n'a pas de
sénateur car il y avait bien et bien
Stéphane Ravier le directeur des
Bouches-du-Rhône mais à la dernière
présidentielle il est parti rejoindre
les rangs d'Éric Zemmour et de
reconquête donc la direction du
rassemblement national compte bien
remédier à cette situation et regarder
ce que disait Marine Le Pen en septembre
dernier c'était la rentrée de son parti
au Cap d'Agde et elle affirmait les
prochaines élections sénatoriales
corrigeront je l'espère cette
inconvenance démocratique qui perdure au
Sénat et je lance d'ores et déjà un
appel au maire aux grands électeurs
attachés au pluralisme à se mobiliser
avec nous pour la défense de cette
démocratie de proximité que sont les
communes même les plus petites alors
dans cette optique et bien le parti du
rassemblement national se prépare
activement à la quasi-totalité des
candidats au sénatoriales sont investis
sur le terrain les à 88 députés RN sont
même mobilisés pour aller à la rencontre
des mers et des conseils municipaux qui
composent le collège de grands électeurs
qui élisent les sénateurs et l'objectif
c'est notamment de parler aux maires
sans étiquette et d'évoquer le travail
les propositions les amendements qui ont
été faits et défendu par les députés
graines depuis un an à l'Assemblée
nationale et parmi les départements qui
sont visés par le RN dans ces élections
sénatoriales il y a notamment le Nord le
Pas-de-Calais la Moselle et puis aussi
la Haute-Marne Mayotte ce sont des
territoires où le RN est plutôt bien
implantés et aussi les
Pyrénées-Orientales puisque le parti
dirige la ville de Perpignan alors
est-ce que le RN pourrait former un
groupe au Sénat c'est à dire avoir plus
de 10 sénateurs alors malgré toutes ces
ambitions malgré cette stratégie sur le
terrain cela semble peu probable que le
RN est un groupe politique au Sénat
c'est à dire au moins 10 sénateurs parce
que ça dépend du mode de scrutin de ces
élections sénatoriales on le rappelle
dans chaque département ce sont et dans
ce corps de grands électeurs 95% de
conseillers municipaux le reste sont des
conseillers régionaux départementaux et
des parlementaires qui élisent les
sénateurs donc ce sont les résultats des
dernières élections municipales qui
donnent la tendance du résultat des
élections sénatoriales et le problème
c'est que le RN en 2020 lors des
dernières élections municipales a fait
un piètre résultat puisqu'il n'a gagné
que 16 communes sur les 35000 que compte
le pays donc c'est peu probable qu'il y
ait 10 sièges de sénateurs en septembre
prochain l'objectif c'est plutôt de
faire mieux quand 2014 ou à l'époque le
Front national avait pour la première
fois de son histoire fait entrer deux
élus au Palais du Luxembourg et puis
cette campagne de terrain de proximité
vis-à-vis des élus locaux et bien elle a
un autre objectif à plus long terme ce
sont les élections municipales 2026 où
là et bien le but c'est vraiment de
corriger ce manque d'implantation locale
du RN merci à Alexandre pour toutes ces
informations Hugo palais est assez c'est
quoi c'est peut-être l'un des principaux
échecs de Marine Le Pen
la difficulté ou l'incapacité de de
créer cet ancrage local notamment aux
élections municipales
il y a des victoires relatives malgré
tout ils ont conquis un certain nombre
de vies ils ont qu'aucune conquis
notamment une grande ville qui est assez
grande ville qui est Perpignan donc
c'est vrai que sa raison ils sont forts
plus les villes sont petites puissent
c'est ça même sans aucun ancrage
militant c'est un peu ça le paradoxe
alors il y a des ancrages militants
notamment dans le Pas-de-Calais par
exemple mais globalement le parti reste
faible on insiste trop peu sur en
réalité les incapacités de du
rassemblement national qui date de très
loin en réalité par exemple la très
faible la très grande faiblesse de
l'encadrement des cadres du RN ça date
de maigrir enfin du départ de Maigret
d'ailleurs et depuis n'ont jamais réussi
à en réalité combler ce déficit de cas
ils essayent là en créant une école de
formation dirigée par un sondeur qui est
Jérôme Sainte Marie mais
bon on verra ce que ça donne à ce stade
les parlementaires n'ont pas
véritablement fait la preuve et
parlementaires RN non pas vraiment fait
la preuve qu'il y avait eu un grand
progrès de ce point de vue là enfin il
faut aller regarder justement c'est pas
très c'est pas très fort de ce point on
y reviendra sur l'isolement on va dire
relatif de Marine Le Pen mais j'aimerais
vous entendre Marie mollet sur voilà le
les difficultés du rassemblement
national à remporté plus de mairies à
centrer localement comment vous
l'analysez effectivement
Perpignan en 2020 c'était un peu l'arbre
qui cachait la forêt d'un échec relatif
c'est-à-dire que en réalité c'est donc
16 mairies RN effectivement les bastions
ont été gardées les scores ont été
renforcés dans les bastions qui avaient
déjà été gagnées mais en fait ils n'ont
pas réussi c'est le grand échec de
Marine Le Pen en disant de présidente à
la tête du RL l'ancrage local c'est
c'est le grand échec ça s'est vu de
nouveau aux régionales ou en 2021 elle a
perdu des conseillers régionaux donc
c'est effectivement la mission de Jordan
Bardella c'est-à-dire réussir là où elle
a échoué et pourquoi et bien notamment
parce que il manque de bras au
rassemblement national il manque de
militants pour aller et bien
labourer ce terrain et il manque
effectivement de formation et on le voit
quand on suit le groupe aussi à
l'Assemblée quand on s'assoit en tribune
ce sont toujours les mêmes qui prennent
la parole il y a quelques visages qui
ont émergés lors la Valette aux aménagé
par exemple mais en réalité c'est une
poignée et parmi les 88 députés et bien
enfin la plupart reste dans l'ombre et
ne participant en tout cas à la partie
visible du travail parlementaire
c'est quand même une vraie question
est-ce que le Sénat peut indéfiniment
rester un bastion sans RN c'est-à-dire
de représentativité je sais ce sont les
règles c'est ça fonctionne comme ça
voilà ce sont les règles elle s'applique
bon sauf à vouloir complètement
transformer le Sénat et en faire une
chambre socio-économique comme l'avait
rêver général de Gaulle et d'autres
d'ailleurs mais là serait quand l'État
on voit difficilement comment le RN
pourrait progresser au Sénat sachant
comme municipal la vraie difficulté
c'est avoir des listes le RN a beaucoup
de mal à avoir des candidats au
municipales donc il faut y voir voilà
une comment ça s'explique il y a encore
chez certains la réticence à s'afficher
les reines je crois qu'il y a toujours
une réticence à s'afficher RN
sur une sur une liste avec son visage
avec la difficulté à assumer aussi
complètement ce programme et puis voilà
c'est cette école de cadre elle a pour
l'instant pas produit beaucoup d'effets
juste pour aller dans votre sens je me
souviens d'un reportage que j'ai fait
que j'avais fait pour les municipales de
2020 pour RTL où j'étais allé en
porte-à-porte avec la tête de liste à
Istres qui n'avait pas assez de
personnes pour faire une liste justement
il faisait du porte-à-porte pour aller
glaner des colistiers et peu importe qui
c'était elle proposait même aux femmes
de ne pas mettre leur nom d'état civil
de mettre leur nom de jeune fille pour
ne pas avoir à s'afficher ce qui montre
que la normalisation a aussi ses limites
encore pour pour le moment et bien
effectivement oui c'est ce marquer au
fer rouge à certains endroits que de
s'afficher à rassemblement national donc
oui effectivement propose aux femmes de
ne pas s'afficher avec leur vrai nom
pour pouvoir constituer une liste quand
il y en a il y a pas où il y a pas assez
de monde pour constituer une liste alors
on va chez un scrutin qui est
historiquement favorable au
rassemblement national et précédemment
Front national c'est évidemment sont
protection européenne 84 les 11% de
Jean-Marie Le Pen c'est un peu le
l'éruption de Jean-Marie Le Pen sur la
scène politique française il Go pas
l'été en tout cas à ce niveau de de
résultat est-ce que il considère que
c'est une élection presque gagnée
d'avance les européennes dans laquelle
ils sont forcés de bien figurer ce que
je veux dire je sais pas ça j'ai pas
leur retour leur retour après juste pour
revenir un tout petit peu sur sur le
point précédent je pense que ce que ça
montre par ailleurs ce degré enfin
encore limité de normalisation c'est que
la stratégie consistant à démasquer le
Front national sur ce rassemblement
national aujourd'hui sur ses
fondamentaux sur son programme etc à une
certaine effectivité c'est qu'elle
empêche son ancrage militant et
électoral au plan local et donc sa
construction qu'il faudrait le faire en
tant qu'appareil que certains opposants
ouvrent national ne le font pas tout à
fait alors je vous pose la question que
je posais à Hugo le palettage vous la
pose à vous sur sur cette perspective
des européennes comment il l'a comment
il l'anticipe au rassemblement national
ils disent que c'est une élection facile
voilà c'est leur terme c'est une
élection facile Jordan Bardella était
arrivé en tête de peu le but c'est de
nouveau d'arriver en tête si possible
d'aller vampiriser les lectorats d'Éric
Zemmour des millions et demi de
personnes pour venir grossir les rangs
si possible tuer LR le rassemblement
national fait le pari de la disparition
de LR aux européennes c'est-à-dire moins
de 5% c'est-à-dire pas d'euros député
aux élections donc effectivement le but
c'est de cranter selon le terme utilisé
dans l'état-major et de récupérer de
capitaliser sur les retraites aux
prochaines échéances électorales que
sont les européennes après Marie parle
de la droite mais l'un des autres échecs
de Marine Le Pen c'est que elle fait
peut-être venir à elle des électeurs de
droite mais contrairement à ce qu'elle
avait annoncé et souhaitée il n'y a pour
l'instant aucun cadre notable des
républicains qui a fait la bascule et
qui souhaiterait un accord avec le
rassemblement national il y a même
erikiotique et décrit par ses O comme
quelqu'un qui serait idéologiquement
proche du rassemblement national a
toujours mis une frontière hermétique
avec le rassemblement national donc là
dessus elle a échoué ces dernières
années on a vu alors certes d'anciens
comme Thierry Mariani comme Jean-Paul
Garraud rejoindre le rassemblement
national mais c'était quand même des
élus en tout cas de seconde division et
pour l'instant il n'y a pas une
mouvement majeur personne dans les
cadres du bureau politique des
républicains dit il faut passer un
accord avec le RN avec Marine Le Pen
fabrique petit Willi intervenir oui
rappelons les chiffres Jordan Bardella
avait obtenu 24% je crois aux dernières
élections européennes ils avaient déjà
vampirisé la liste LR qui était conduite
par François-Xavier Bellani avec un
positionnement très à droite très
conservateur on voit que ça avait pas
été une très très bonne stratégie donc
là c'est vrai que atteindre 23 24% ça
paraît assez raisonnable pour le
rassemblement national et donc l'enjeu
ça sera plutôt de voir ce qui se passe
du côté de gauche de l'échiquier
politique reste avec vous est-ce que le
nom Le Pen peut-être un frein à
l'accession au pouvoir du rassemblement
national
ah derrière il y a une hérédité il y a
un passif il y a un passé donc oui moi
je pense que la marque Le Pen elle parle
aux électeurs mais elle a aussi des
limites tout à fait oui votre avis
là-dessus Marie
je crois aussi que le patronyme est
encore un poids ça veut pas dire que
30 % plus un enfin je veux dire jusqu'à
quel point ça reste un frein c'est c'est
ça la question c'est oui ça reste un
frein bien sûr voilà Patrick Buisson on
l'a entendu l'ancien conseiller de
Nicolas Sarkozy lui continue de dire que
elle ne sera jamais élue parce que c'est
une Le Pen et que c'est un fardeau trop
lourd pour accéder au pouvoir
exactement donc
c'est difficile à dire en réalité
jusqu'à quel point c'est encore un frein
nous verrons mais effectivement pour
revenir sur sur ce que disait Guillaume
la question de DLR et des mains tendues
on voit Jordan Bardella qui tend des
mains découverte à François-Xavier
Bellamy ou Nadine Morano eurodéputé LR
et aujourd'hui ses mains elles ne sont
pas saisies elles seront très
probablement pas saisis jusqu'aux
européennes et ça reste on parlait de la
question de l'accession pouvoir la
question des alliances et la question de
la solitude c'est un des grands freins à
son accession au pouvoir qui pour
gouverner avec Marine Le Pen les seuls
qui ont saisi ça peut-être c'est
finalement plus les élus enfin les
députés qui ont vu leur l'état électoral
de leur circonscription ce qu'on a vu au
travers de la motion de censure c'est
globalement quand vous regardez les
députés qui ont voté la motion de
censure les députés républicains qui ont
voté la motion de censure c'est pour la
plupart ceux qui ont un RN extrêmement
haut dans leur circonscription et ça ne
leur avait pas échappé que Jordan
baerella avait dit ce qui vote notre
motion la prochaine fois législative on
ne mettra pas de candidat face à eux je
reviens sur la question de d'une
alternative interne à Marine Le Pen vu
comment fonctionne le rassemblement
national est-ce que on peut imaginer
c'est dans 4 ans un autre que Marine Le
Pen tête de liste à la présidentielle
décide que ce sera elle ce sera elle
c'est aussi la légitimité en quelque
sorte patrimonial après sur vous
répondre à votre question ça n'est un
frein le nom que enfin ça n'est pas un
frein si on continue de faire des
interviews où on lui demande si comment
aller avec ses chats et si on découvre
le programme réel du Front national dans
seulement dans l'entre-deux tours ce qui
s'est quand même passé la dernière fois
c'est que pendant des mois on a peu
décrypter le programme du Front National
et ça c'est fait en gros dans
l'entre-deux-tours en se disant ah tiens
peut-être qu'elle a une chance de gagner
cette fois là enfin elle a pas gagné
mais elle avait fait 8 points de plus
presque plus de 3 millions de fois plus
donc la question c'est surtout comment
l'élite pour moi comment l'élite
politique va continuer de traiter enfin
une des questions c'est les politiques
mais aussi médiatique va continuer à
traiter Marine Le Pen ou va traiter
Marine Le Pen dans les dans les quatre
années à venir comme une alternance
tranquille et normale ou voilà ou comme
quelque chose d'autre qui relève de la
effectivement de la famille de l'extrême
droite et donc qui porte un projet
particulièrement dangereux je voudrais
qu'on regarde quelques un sondages
récents 20 avril sondage Ifop qui qui
fait un comparatif entre Emmanuel Macron
et Marine Le Pen alors ça on vous a pas
de vous donner mais on va vous donner
déjà le thème et le résultat général des
deux personnalités suivantes voilà la
question posée laquelle préférez-vous
elle arrive devant Emmanuel Macron
Marine Le Pen avait 45 % pour 42% au
président de la République ensuite moi
j'ai choisi deux catégories sociaux
professionnels que je trouve
intéressantes auprès des ouvriers même
question posées auprès des ouvriers là
elle est très très largement en tête
Marine Le Pen 61% des ouvriers préfèrent
Marine Le Pen 25% Emmanuel Macron et si
on regarde une autre catégorie qui est
la catégorie des artisans commerçants là
aussi une victoire assez large de
l'ancienne candidat du Rassemblement
national 53% 37% pour Emmanuel Macron
marie-molley sur les traits d'image
parce que c'est intéressant aussi de de
voir ça permet d'évaluer un peu le
comment un personnage évolue aux yeux
des électeurs français quels sont les
traits d'images qui ressort en ce moment
pour moi alors effectivement Marine Le
Pen est très méfiante sur les bons
sondages elle a payé pour voir des
excellents sondages régionales même pour
lors de la présidentielle elle finit
toujours plus bas elle finit toujours
plus bas on a eu du 49-51 % elle perdait
mais à 49 %. donc elle se méfie il y a
une étude effectivement qui attiré
l'attention dans l'état-major du RN
c'est l'étude le sondage ifope sur les
traits d'image il y a trois semaines
dans laquelle pour la première fois elle
apparaît compétente pour une majorité de
Français 52% plus 6 points sur un an et
ça c'est la mer des batailles pour
Marine Le Pen en scène de la compétence
et de battre en brèche cette éternelle
procès en incompétence qui lui colle à
la peau elle a tenté de le combattre
tout au long de la présidentielle quitte
à mettre en sourdine l'immigration mais
à publier des livres blancs des livres
noirs des chiffrages c'était une pluie
de deux chiffres pour tenter ce
crédibiliser parce qu'elle sait que
c'est sa grande difficulté c'est ce que
nous disait ce que nous disons encore
les cas c'est de dire la difficulté
c'est que aujourd'hui encore
certains Français pensent que si on
arrive au pouvoir la France s'effondre
voilà c'est c'est la mère des batailles
donc ça effectivement c'est c'est le
grand sujet la stature présidentielle
aussi je crois
progresse plus oui de mémoire donc voilà
ça c'est effectivement des éléments qui
n'ont pas échappé ni à Marine Le Pen et
à son entourage merci beaucoup merci à
tous d'avoir participé à ce débat je
vais rappeler Hugo pas l'état le titre
de votre livre la nouvelle
internationale fasciste livre qui est
publiée aux éditions textuelles je vous
dis à demain pour un nouveau numéro de
sens public vous pouvez également
retrouver cette émission en replay sur
notre nouvelle plateforme public
sénat.fr la nôtre et toutes les autres
émissions de la chaîne évidemment belle
soirée
[Musique]